guys we got five pizzas let's go yo what
the we doing get the back here let's
make some pizza let's
[Music]
go today I'm going to see if I have what
it takes to survive a shift at one of
America's craziest slice joints I'd say
the biggest obstacle that they're going
to run into is just the pace if you're
looking at like our traditional week
weekend we're burning through like 300
pies working beside me in the kitchen
will be YouTuber knife drop author and
Master Chef finalist Nick djovani one of
the pieces of advice I definitely would
give is speed making sure you're keeping
up with the orders because ORD is come
fast and you definitely have to learn
how to move fast Tony balony is known
for its outrageous over-the-top
Creations what pizza shop you going to
walk into with three tacos on a slice or
like a mountain of pepperoni nowhere and
the Shop's owner Mike Hal is planning to
put us through two different challenges
today first basic dough stretching and a
Sprint to complete a plain cheese pizza
then a rush order to see if we can crank
out a full ticket of Tony's wildest pies
we hold everyone to a really high
standard here consistency is super
important so if you can't hang go back
downstairs start washing dishes come up
when you're
ready I'm happy to have you guys both
here we're going to make some Pizza get
down and dirty you never worked in a
restaurant right I'm scared as hell to
work in this restaurant at that I'm a
home pizza chef and I did everything
myself the prep baked all the pies and
even sometimes I delivered the pies too
but this right here is volume this right
here is a system and I have to say it
seems a little overwhelming but I'm game
I'm going to try to just nail it how do
you feel about working here today A
Pizza Shop's different I've worked in
plenty of professional kitchens but
never have I worked in a place like this
that does this kind of volume when you
walk into a pizza joint you know the
second you go into that kitchen you are
going to get flour all over here you're
going to get some sauce you're going to
get messy remembering each and every
single ingredient that goes on every
individual Pizza while being fast I'm
prepared to sweat everyone here in Tony
balone land is like family they're all
day ones and not only are we pumping out
an incredible product but it's all
homemade we do our process and our
things and most times experienced chefs
that come from legit restaurants are
like how do you do this and we get it
done it's style though and you guys are
going to start getting backed up because
we're going to get some heavy orders in
here you guys ready to get it started
yes n we don't say that what do we say
[__] yeah let's go come on let's
go dough is the foundation of any good
pizza and on top of that when you do the
volume that we do and you have 200 to
300 pies com out of this station you got
to have that right and you got to be
able to toss that dough prep it stretch
it get it on the pizza peel in the oven
out of the oven garnish it box it and
get it to the customer we need to do it
and do it [__] hard okay okay okay
all right let's go open the door right
here pop that open these four doors pull
them out y yal yal yal you take your
hand grip it a little bit from the edges
and then immediately turn it over oh in
your hand like this what I you do it
smells great smells good no time for
[__] smell it over here let's go FL
we take it like this we put it inside of
here we shake get back and forth nice
and easy as you can tell it's really
soft so you got to move fast take it out
and put it down on your counter just
like that let's see it Nicole all right
let's go shake it shake it shake shake
it shake it shake it turn it over turn
it over there you go you go now clean up
your station let's get these out of here
all right take it up space go [__] yeah
F say yes chef and I want you to feel it
it's going to be a little sticky in
Parts get a little more of that flower
mixture sprinkled on top what I want you
to do is we're not going to be tossing
in the air we're not wearing a [__]
white dirty tank top on the Boardwalk in
Atlantic City smoking a cigarette hoing
at girls in the summertime so we're not
tossing in the air what we're going to
do is take our hand slightly up like
this take your left hand put it under
your right back in the same position
crisscross applesauce but I leave the
dough on the surface and then as soon as
it's like maybe 18 in you're good I'm
good put it down that's it put it down
18 in is what we're going for so guys
you got a minute and a half Max I want
the pizza on the peel stretched out
ready to go 18 in in the oven within a
minute and a half on your mark get set
go okay let's go two all right I got I
got the top off there you
go all right oh wait claw claw claw pull
it over take it out uh oh come on wait
come on Nicole we got this Nicole we're
going to fix it Nicole okay got it like
this boom in here boom
down I I ruined my you didn't ruin it
you're good 35 seconds in I'm feeling
pretty good about about this so far it's
hard to do it fast though yeah it's not
easy to do it fast I'm going to get
cheese marinara or vodka sauce whatever
you want P's got a ladle and a half to
two ladles I'm making a 12 in 55 seconds
in got Ladle I'm going to go for the
Vodka let's go all right all right we're
a minute and five okay put some of this
dope looking cheese right here okay bam
ready you got to get it in the oven
first Shuffle it got 7 Seconds To Go
seconds okay oh wow bam just made it
that was good made yeah that was good my
hand I don't care you got work so our
ovens cook at about 600° so we're at
like a 7 to 8 and 1/2 minute cook time
depending on the pizza this is not how I
make pizza at home I think the biggest
difference is that we're standing right
in front of a 600° oven you're not
dealing with that heat at home and the
heat gets to your head and the heat gets
to your body and it makes you tired and
it's very very difficult I felt pretty
good about this I wanted to get the
perfectly Circle Pizza yeah I didn't
quite get there I would have liked to be
a little more creative too I I was
limited by the timing there to get
really fancy with the toppings I think
the challenges these are very unique
sort of dishes that they sit in and you
really have to make sure that you got it
off if it hooks which which it can hook
anywhere really you're done those two
pies that you made were absolutely
horrifically terrible but you guys did
great you guys are amazing everything is
going to be great they were just
terrible I'm bringing the heavy hitter
this is Benny he's been with me since
day one Benny go go Benny go he's
straight he's straight family and
straight absolute killer so this is how
fast you need to go he's beasting it
right now he's got to move he clips and
if you notice he works clean and he's a
leader
toning
okay um all right
gotcha all right guys on order we have
two I will [__] smash you and two
Jewish Cowboys that's it this is stage
two next level is the real application
we got to go let's run through these
pies one by one now first the Jewish
cowboy is our dough tossed down in our
flour breadcrumb mixture then smoked
mozzarella shredded dry age schort
mozzarella it's got my grandma's 8 Hour
roasted brisket my grandma's brisket
sauce on it then it goes in the oven and
then we got my grandma's Babushka sauce
and then a little bit of herb parsley
the whole
plate on a goddamn pizza that's number
one two of those pies St secondly we got
two I will [__] smash shoes it's a
Smash Burger Pizza First We Take It and
Roll It in sesame seeds then we put
dryed kamorta we put our smashed Burgers
down caramelized onion we put a little
smoked mozzarella you get in the [__]
oven it comes out of the oven sour half
dill pickles all around it and then more
smash sauce and this is what you guys
got to do oh my goodness you have 10
minutes to get these orders in the oven
out of the oven to box into the customer
get two pies out let's toss them up and
get them stretched out use those same
techniques as we did before let me get a
little flower on here for you guys help
you out a little bit oh I got it out
this time there you go beautiful right
in the pan all I want you to do is pull
it like this you can open it up got it
this is getting thin so you don't want
to focus on that part no cheese on the
peel too you want to keep this peel
really nice and clean all right we're a
minute and five if you get big chunks I
want you to open up those big chunks
like that you could swirl Out ooh yes
you start from the top and zigzag your
way back down we're going to take this
mozzarella 13 slices
total uh we lacking on time you got to
go get in the oven right over there all
right Nick you're going in woo so now
that that's baking we have one more
pizza to make I will [__] smash you
Smash Burger Pizza do just the crust in
sesame seeds we have to move it sideways
like this and roll it
quickly that just the crust maybe it's a
carnival wheel toss the corn but you're
on the corn you're a basket you're going
around like te at this place yeah just
like that perfect lot now put it on your
peel great technique great stretching
great stretching I feel like we're
already both learning I mean if you look
here I think already the shapes that
we're getting are both a little bit more
round better yeah I also think you can
start doing it without looking down so
much I can feel where that edge of the
pizza is I can flip it over using the
back of my hands it becomes more feel
then look I like it in here I kind of
like the heat of a good kitchen like
this there's something about it that
gets me very excited and I like to move
fast that was great all right guys the
caramelized onions three scoops of
onions total on the burger I feel
overwhelmed next thing you know we do
our smash sauce napin you apron apron
what do you think you go to a restaurant
and you see someone sitting there
outside smoking a cigarette with a dirty
a y' I want to eat that place go circle
circle circle circle you got better with
the circle that looks good ready guys
yes Oho this is heavy all right there
you go you got it beautiful you got it
right there wherever you think you fit
yeah that is beautiful beautiful wow
we're going to pull these Jewish Cowboys
out yes all right good first one's out
let's go we had another one got another
one let's go let's go box from the
bottom pizza box box from the bottom
watch me knock down all the boxes
though there I made it all right here we
go beautiful oo in the pizza box nice
that's a little more pickles a little
bit more pickles a little more hustle a
little bit more hustle sorry sorry sorry
grab that pizza cutter grab the pizza
cutter snack it down hard right to the
end twist smack it down stay in one spot
too back there twist he oh I'm telling
you I got this after we get done topping
it we'll cut it up chop it up let's go
let's go we got 30 seconds to go okay we
got to get these pies out [__]
customers waiting let's go let's go all
right all right all right woo yo 9
minutes and 52 seconds we did it we did
it wow great job these C getting some
awesome piz oh my
[Music]
goodness okay mik don't hold back how
did Nick and I do today your first
stretch in pie were pretty [__]
deplorable tell you the truth but I got
to tell you stage two you guys got a
little better and by that second I will
[__] smash your pizza I trip those
pies to customers they look really
really really good you know coming into
a restaurant like this is a very
different story than anything I've done
in the past There's Something about
making pizza that's more almost of an
art than anything you have to get every
detail perfect a pizza is a beautiful
thing and I feel like I got a few steps
closer to being able to do that art
today you know to be honest this process
is a little overwhelming for me I'm
going to be honest there's a lot of
ingredients there's a lot of different
PES a lot of things you have to memorize
but under good supervision great
instructors and a system I can do
[Music]
anything